hello this is Nick Offerman and I'm
doing the wire to auto-complete
interview why this probably gets typed
in the most why Nick Offerman is Nick
Offerman attractive clearly is Nick
Offerman married hell yeah girl twenty
years is Nick Offerman a ballet dancer
surprisingly yes I had two semesters of
ballet and I still got it
follow-up question what is my favorite
ballet I ever danced the third his Nick
Offerman anything like Ron Swanson sure
he looks and sounds an awful lot like
him
loves meat loves making things with wood
loves scotch particularly Lagavulin
single malt and he really gets Randy for
women that look like Megan Mullally is
Nick Offerman show appropriate for kids
yeah if you're talking about my touring
show which i think is what they're
asking if your kids are conservative
they might get their feelings a little
bit hurt when I intimate that they're
indecent his Nick Offerman really a
woodworker yes in fact I was a carpenter
and then I became a scenery carpenter
then I became a woodworker and I still
AM is Nick Offerman in cats is that a
sex thing is Nick Offerman Canadian no
but thank you I took that as a
compliment
is Nick Offerman left-handed he is not
is Nick Offerman funny sometimes is Nick
Offerman missing a tooth I have the
teeth I have let's leave it at that
his Nick Offerman a minister goddamn
right I am actually a minister I've
married some people I'm registered with
one that's cool online churches not to
brag what is Nick Offerman
drinking mainly water when I was younger
that would have been beer what does Nick
Offerman look like now that a trick
question
this is a visual medium right a lot like
this I'm sorry if you are vision
impaired like a handsomer George Clooney
what does Nick Offerman drive if two
vehicles my sensible vehicle is an Audi
that is for mileage and safety and
parking ability then at my shop I have a
Ford f250 super duty diesel which is for
hauling pieces of trees what does Nick
Offerman do for a living this what
college what college did Nick Offerman
go to the University of Illinois at
champaign-urbana does Nick Offerman play
a guitar he does he placed several does
Nick Offerman have tattoos he does two
one on each Python one is a is a heart
Viney thing with a rose the rose looks
kind of like lady parts let's call it a
Georgia O'Keeffe rose and it has a
banner that says mater Latin for mother
it's my
tenshun other tattoo the other one is
are the sort of Mississippi Indian band
wraparound with an ankh right here and
that tattoo says I'm a very big fan of
the Red Hot Chili Peppers right after
blood sugar sex Magik came out and I
stand by it does Nick Offerman have
siblings yes I have three two sisters
and a brother all magnificent creatures
does Nick Offerman have a podcast he
does it's called in bed with Nick and
Megan and it's driven it's the
brainchild of Nick Offerman's wife or me
I'm Nicola of my wife she thought of it
I get to do it with her
that makes Nick Offerman lucky did Nick
Offerman die no why this probably gets
typed in the most why Nick Offerman why
Nick Offerman hates the Internet why why
anyone in their right mind hates the
Internet
have you seen it why does Nick Offerman
say fremulon
my friend and hero Mike Schur who wrote
on Saturday Night Live he wrote on the
office also plays Mose Schrute super fun
fact created Parks and Rec created
Brooklyn nine-nine when we were making
Parks and Rec they were making their
producer card for Brooklyn nine-nine for
his company called fremulon he asked me
to say fremulon and it's the greatest
compliment I've ever received why is
Nick Offerman so popular there's no
accounting for taste
how Nick Offerman stays in character
it's all in the breath how is Nick
Offerman beard style I asked
myself that every day hello am nick
offerman beard style
I think that's improper grammar beard
style nick offerman today am heavy
stubble how did nick offerman become
famous to the degree that he did by
winning the actor lottery and being cast
in the role of ron swanson on parks and
recreation how to meet Nick Offerman
politely how did Nick Offerman
meet Megan Mullally we met doing a play
in Los Angeles called the Berlin circle
by Chuck me thank my lucky stars Chuck
may is a cool absurdist writer he calls
himself a collage writer and has
characters like Erich Honecker
and and Megan played New York socialite
Pamela Harriman and it ended with the
celebratory everybody gets together and
sings The Beatles all you need is love
in German all a block and liebe I
believe and the rest is history
put a ring on that can Nick Offerman
sing goddamn right can Nick Offerman
actually play the saxophone oh hell yeah
can Nick Offerman a break dance I don't
know can he
was nick offerman in the military
no has Nick Offerman hosted SNL no Lorne
Nick Offerman freemason we met on the
level we parted on a square Nick
Offerman Baywatch almost Nick Offerman
is my spirit animal and believe that is
no longer a cool thing to say
politically cultural appropriation from
Native Americans so now you have to say
my inner beast please and thank you my
inner beast Tim Curry as frankfurter in
Rocky Horror Picture Show Frank N Furter
Nick Offerman Lord of the Rings Nick
Offerman quotes to live by stick around
coming up any moment now Nick Offerman
shirts on making it some our flannel by
the Carhartt clothing company some the
denim looking ones are made by a cool
company in Hartford Connecticut hard and
co check them out their stuff is dope
Nick Offerman you'll log a brilliant
idea by a young man named David Phillips
I shoot commercials for Lagavulin Scotch
one of them for Christmas is me sitting
by a roaring fireplace meant to be put
on the television to accompany your
office party your family gathering as I
sip scotch in a satisfied manner you're
welcome
nick offerman quotes about love love is
where it's at it all turns on affection
I feel pretty like that was pretty nice
and harmless and I'm surprised frankly
you know that there weren't any like why
don't we put Nick Offerman in prison